now time for paul's picks thanks to
taylormade productions for sponsoring
this segment summer is in full swing and
entertaining expert paul zone is back
with us with his must-haves to keep you
glowing and going this season welcome
back thanks for having me there's a lot
going on this time of year right a lot
going on okay whether it's for your skin
or whether you're going shopping or
events
yes yes let's start with skincare let's
start with skincare with this wonderful
duo from olay with their niacinamide
plus peptide 24. okay so what this is
going to do is going to help with the
wrinkles it's going to help hydrate
because it's so hot and so dry here in
las vegas so it's going to help with
that it's going to help to correct
uneven tones and it's healthier looking
skin with 99 pure niacinamide and you
might say paul why is this in the
package because it's a two pack and you
pop into sam's tub
yes if you pop into sam's club you get
eight dollars off between now and august
7th so that's that's right and that's
just one time application at night put
it on put it on the morning at night get
that hydration going we need it all
right what's next speaking of hydration
next up we have some back to school
meals made easy with smart finals so i
love smart and final it is one trip and
that's it they have everything you need
including this line called sun harvest
which is organic and it's much more cost
effective and they also have a green
line of things like compostable forks
and spoons in detergent and everything
like that so it's better for your wallet
and it's better for mother nature
breakfast is made easy right here with
some granola and some peanut butter nut
clusters we've got some peanut butter so
you know one click and that's it if you
go to smartandfinal.com and they have an
app so download the app and you'll love
it smart final makes it easy yes they
make it so easy so easy and what about
the summer drink oh yeah next up we have
absolute so absolute has teamed up with
garcelle bouvier to create this fun
front yard citrus situation here so you
know absolute vodka is a perfect
cocktail for any summer soiree so
they've created this cooler together
inspired by the different flavors so
this is the lime they have grapefruit
they have citron they have a wide
variety of different flavors of coolers
and so not only is it a table but it's
also a cooler so you fill this with ice
and everybody go to the front yard get
together have an absolute cocktail and
really celebrate that's a great backyard
the balcony where can you get that you
can get this at reservebar.com order it
and then it's a great gift too for a
summerslaughter
i definitely i agree i agree okay next
up summer shopping summer shopping back
to school back to school the kids are
going back to school well jcpenney has
you covered it's your one stop shop for
all things back to school for the kids
they have a wide variety of items from
classics like this fun denim jacket
right here they have denim pants they
have these cute shoes and they're such
great prices you can go to jcpenney or
jcp.com and they have all they have
husky they have adaptive clothes so it's
really for every kid in every ability
and they have coupons i love a good
coupon at jcpenney.com because hello
everybody's on the budget this time of
year right exactly and back to school
for the kids but also for the parents
too exactly
too all right and last but certainly not
least um coffee cocktails i love a
coffee cocktail so we have some liquor
43 so this is the most popular spanish
liqueur in the world it's 43 natural
ingredients and i get a lot of vanilla
from it so it makes a wonderful cocktail
called the carrijo so it's a shot of
espresso a shot of the liquor 43 and
it's absolutely delicious and we also
have a horchata with liquor 43 that is
actually vegan so it's delicious you can
do a fun little pina colada with that
you can pick these up a total wine or
drizzly has been my best friend the past
couple years you go on drizzly app and
they will deliver it to you you can have
wonderful cocktails you have the best
tips that's why you're the entertaining
expert okay thank you so much paul for
being here these are great